here's what's good about 30 is that you
drink through your mouth instead of
pouring alcohol into a funnel into your
butt that's that's the new craze I don't
consider 30 old per se I consider it on
the way up 30 is midlife crisis and then
you find yourself we're not here the age
30 I think of better you know more
wisdom I don't I don't I don't want be
30 years old it does it does
that's the scary part is that you go to
bed 29 you wake up 30 and it's the same
light like everyone said midlife crisis
that's not yeah that's the weird one
it's funny what they don't realize is
that the quarter life crisis I feel like
is actually pretty true like what you
get out of college and then you're like
what am I doing with you yes see I think
the quarter life crisis is just you have
to pay rent parties will be irrelevant
because I'll be too old parties will be
ending early party totally boring 30
year olds just drink wine and let's have
a night watching SVU parties at 30
actually get a lot better because the
parties that you're going to now are
just loud music and skunk beer oh and
sweat and sweat and shame maybe this is
good or bad but I still host a lot of
parties that go till 4:00 a.m. where did
you get that we altering wine all the
time had wine before wine will become
your best friend in your 30s maybe ditch
the boxed wine when you leave the
party's over so it doesn't really matter
what time is when I leave hopefully boys
will be men by the time I'm up they're
gonna be the best or not I mean maybe
they need to be like 35 I don't know I
feel like by the time I turned 30 I
really wouldn't care what people think
at all depending on how cool my 20s are
maybe I'll be married but nobody will
know that I am 30 when I'm 30 everyone's
gonna think I'm still 29 right now I'm
still kind of in that like teenage
mindset where I feel like everyone's
like criticizing me but
when I'm 30 I just wanna I just want to
live will be the wine night 30 year olds
who are like oh those twenty year olds
don't know what they're doing they sure
huh the only thing that I've learned
from twenty to thirty is that I don't
know anything once you realize that you
don't know [ __ ] then you know [ __ ]
then then you know [ __ ] you definitely
come into your own and it's you feel so
much more comfortable just being
yourself if you think that that women
are gonna get better by the time they're
30 just wait to you have a 40 year old
the answer is you're not gonna be where
you think you are yeah toe it's deep
there's one last thing I'd like to say
fireball is delicious
awful Oh none of these fools know what
the talks about